بتاعها جياني انفانتينو رئيس الاتحاد
الدولي لكره القدم خلال قمه العشرين في
بالي دعا الى انتهاج فرصه انطلاق كاس
العالم قطر 2022 ليوقف اطلاق النار في
المناطق المسطره ونشر السلام حول العالم
مضيفا بان الكل مرحب به في قطر
ستكون المره الاولى التي يتم استضافه هذه
البطوله في الشرق الاوسط
ويمكنني ان اؤكد لكم ان قطر والفيفا
جهزتك كل شيء للتاكد ان الجميع مرحب به في
هذا الاحتفال او هذه الاحتفاليه الكبيره
وبالتاكيد جميعكم مرحبا بكم بطوله التي
ستبدا بعد خمسه ايام
ستكونوا المحرك الايجابي واذا دعوتي لكم
جميعا هيا ان تفكروا بوقف اطلاق النار
مؤقت مدته شهر وهي مده كاس العالم او همم
على الاقل القبول بممرات انسانيه اي شيء
يسمح به استعاده الحوار كخطوه اولى للسلام